♪ ♪
>> Tucker: A HUGE NUMBER OF
WELL-KNOWN PEOPLE DISGRACED
THEMSELVES DURING THE TWO YEARS
OF THE RUSSIAN COLLUSION HOAX.
BUT TWO OF THEM STAND ABOVE THE
REST.
FORMER CIA CHIEF JOHN BRENNAN
AND FORMER FBI DIRECTOR JOHN
COMEY.
WE EXPECT LAWMAKERS TO
GRANDSTAND ON FLIMSY PRETEXT,
THAT'S WHAT THEY DO.
WE DON'T EXPECT MUCH OF THE NEWS
MEDIA.
OUR MOST POWERFUL BUREAUCRATS
ARE SUPPOSED TO BE -- THEY NEED
TO BE IMPRESSIVE.
WE NEED THEM TO BE FAIR AND
SMART AND LEVELHEADED.
JOHN BRENNAN HAS SHOWN HIMSELF
TO BE NONE OF THOSE THINGS.
DURING HIS YEARS SERVING
BARACK OBAMA, HE WAS KNOWN
MOSTLY FOR LYING.
UNDER TRUMP HE HAS BECOME A
FULL-BLOWN WILD EYED CONSPIRACY
NOT.
>> HE IS FEEDING AND FUELING
HATRED AND ANIMOSITY AND
MISUNDERSTANDINGS AMONG
AMERICANS.
>> I USE THE TERM THAT THIS IS
NOTHING SHORT OF TREASONOUS
BECAUSE IT IS THE BETRAYAL OF
THE NATION.
HE'S GIVING AID AND COMFORT TO
THE ENEMY.
>> TREASONOUS AS AIDING AND
ABETTING TRUST AS WELL AS THE
ENEMY.
>> JIM COMEY MEANWHILE IS
SMARTER THAN JOHN BRENNAN, NOT
THAT THAT IS HARD BUT HE IS A
POLITICAL PARTISAN.
SOMETHING THAT NO FBI DIRECTOR
SHOULD EVER BE.
AT TIMES HIS JUDGMENT HAS BEEN
BIZARRE.
WATCH FOR EXAMPLE AS THE MOST A
LURID PORTIONS MIGHT IN FACT BE
REAL.
>> I HONESTLY NEVER THOUGHT
THESE WORDS WOULD COME OUT OF MY
MOUTH BUT I DON'T KNOW WHETHER
THE CURRENT PRESIDENT OF
UNITED STATES WAS IN MOSCOW.
>> Tucker: THOSE ARE THE TWO
MOST POWERFUL UNELECTED
BUREAUCRATS AND HE WOULD NOT
HIRE THEM TO RUN A CVS.
THEY ARE IDIOTS, NARCISSUS
OBSERVING A STORY ABOUT SOME P
TAPE THAT RAN ON A CAT BLOG.
AND ADAM SCHIFF IS STILL
RAMBLING ON LIKE A MENTAL
PATIENT ABOUT RUSSIA CONSPIRACY.
>> FROM THE PUBLIC, YOU MIGHT
THINK IT'S OKAY THAT THE ONLY
DISAPPOINTMENT DURING THAT
MEETING WAS AT THE DIRT THEY
RECEIVED ON HOLY CLINTON WASN'T
BETTER.
YOU MIGHT THINK THAT'S OKAY.
I THINK IT'S IMMORAL, UNETHICAL,
UNPATRIOTIC, AND YES.
I THINK IT'S CORRUPT.
AND EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION.
>> IMMORAL, UNETHICAL,
UNPATRIOTIC.
PEOPLE DIDN'T USE TO TALK LIKE
THAT, PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO ARE
ALREADY ALL ALL THREE.
BUT IT'S NOT JUST ADAM SCHIFF.
BILL BARR, THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
LOOKED LIKE A DECENT BUT I COME
IN FACT A LIVING STEREOTYPE OF
THE TRADITIONAL MODERN
REPUBLICAN.
BUT LOOKS DECEIVE.
A PRUDENT STOOGE WORKING
SECRETLY FOR MOTHER RUSSIA AND
HE CANNOT BE TRUSTED.
>> OR MR. BAR TO QUICKLY ISSUE A
FOUR PAGE REPORT IN HIS ATTEMPT
TO TRY TO EXONERATE
PRESIDENT TRUMP AS TOO MUCH OF
THE ODOR OF POLITICAL EXPEDIENCY
TO HELP THE MAN WHO APPOINTED
HIM, PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Tucker: CHUCK SCHUMER SAYS
YOU CAN BE SURE THE ENTIRE HERD
OF BRAINLESS DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE SAY IT,
TOO.
>> I AM DEEPLY TROUBLED BY BAR
HIMSELF.
HE SHOULD HAVE RECUSED HIMSELF
IN MY OPINION.
SO I HAVE A LOT OF PROBLEMS WITH
HIM.
>> DO YOU TRUST BARR'S JUDGMENT
ON OBSTRUCTION HERE?
>> NO.
>> I THINK WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL DID WAS
UNDERMINE THE PURPOSE OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S JOB.
IT WAS NOT ONLY ARROGANT, BUT
DISRESPECTFUL.
>> IT'S VERY HARD TO OVERSTATE
HOW DUMB THIS IS.
WE ARE SEARCHING FOR THE WORDS.
HE'S BEEN THE PUBLIC GUY FOR 40
YEARS.
HE GAVE MONEY TO JEB BUSH'S 2016
CAMPAIGN.
IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE THAT BARR
EVEN VOTED FOR DONALD TRUMP.
FOR SOME REASON, BILL BARR HAS
DEVELOPED SUCH A DEEP LOYALTY TO
DONALD TRUMP THAT HE'S WILLING
TO DESTROY HIS OWN REPUTATION,
SUBVERT AMERICAN GOVERNMENT AND
COMMIT CRIMES.
WHY?
IN ORDER TO HIDE HIS CRIMINAL
RUSSIAN COLLISION.
THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE TELLING
YOU.
IT'S INSANE.
THEY WILL TELL YOU A LOT OF
THINGS LIKE THAT.
WITH REMARKABLE FREQUENCY, THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
THE MOST IMPRESSIVE IN OUR
SOCIETY FALL FOR HOAXES THAT NO
NORMAL PERSON WOULD EVER BELIEV
BELIEVE.
THE SMOLLETT HATE CRIMES, A
DOZEN MORE JUST LIKE IT IN THE
PAST TWO YEARS.
THE FAKE DUKE RATE CASE AND EVEN
FIGURE UVA PATERNITY.
WEAPONS OF MASS DESTRUCTION IN
IRAQ.
THE FRAUDULENT FDA FOOD PYRAMID
THAT HELPED MAKE AMERICA FATTER
AND LESS HEALTHY.
THE MORE BREAKFAST CEREAL, THAT
WILL SLAM YOU DOWN.
THEY BOUGHT ALL OF THIS AND MUCH
MORE WITHOUT EVEN PAUSING.
WHEN THE CREEPY LAWYER TOLD THEM
THAT BRETT KAVANAUGH WAS A
CRIMINAL, THEY BELIEVED HIM.
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE WHO BRAGGED
ABOUT HOW MUCH THEY REVERE
SCIENCE.
AND AT THE SAME TIME INSIST THAT
YOU CAN CHANGE HER BIOLOGICAL BY
WISHING IT SO.
40 YEARS AGO THE SAME PEOPLE
WARNED US THAT A NEW ICE AGE WAS
COMING.
SUPERSTITION RAINS IN ITS PLACE.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
CONVENTIONAL RELIGION, THE ONES
WE ALL MOCK, DIE.
PEOPLE SAY, I'M SECULAR.
JUST FIND SOMETHING EVEN MORE